muy buenas noches cuáles fueron los
motivos de la salida de estos seis
funcionarios justo el mismo día
la razón está en la expresión del
centrado que es una formación política
formada por una decena de partidos que
funcionan como bisagra y tienen un peso
fundamental en prácticamente todos los
gobiernos de brasil desde la transición
democrática hay que recordar que el
central estuvo detrás del impeachment
del ex presidenta dilma rousseff que el
nuevo presidente del parlament o artur
lira también es un miembro destacado del
central
bolsonaro juró y perjuró que no se
aliaría con el central porque quería
renovar la política sin embargo este
grupo de partidos decide todo en
brasilia y sin ellos no se puede
gobernar y por eso bolsonaro se ha
convertido en el presidente que más
dinero ha destinado a este grupo en
forma de enmiendas que es un mecanismo
que tiene el parlamento para que de
senadores y parlamentarios tengan acceso
directo a una parte de los presupuestos
públicos fueron el año pasado 10 17.200
millones de reales equivalentes a unos
tres mil millones de dólares
una forma hay quien dice que él compró
su tranquilidad porque había más de 60
peticiones de impeachment presentadas en
el congreso ahora el centrado estás
cobrando este apoyo desde hace dos
semanas tanto el presidente de la cámara
como el senado se venían reuniendo con
personas destacadas del mundo económico
financiero empresarios que están
cansados del extremismo de evolucionar y
sobre todo de la imagen de brasil fuera
que puede empañar digamos el desarrollo
de las relaciones internacionales la
primera cabeza fue el ministro de salud
eduardo para suelo y hoy se han
producido los cambios
valeria hablemos de la salida de araujo
del ministerio de exteriores y de
acevedo de cartera de la cátedra de
defensa son dos puestos claves pueden
verse como una derrota de bolt sonar
para los analistas brasileños de
política sin duda hay que recordar que
ernesto araújo representaba el ala
ideológica y conservadora del gobierno
es un negacionista que admira las
teorías de terra plan ismo que niega el
calentamiento global que ha pasado el
año de la pandemia atacando china en lo
cual no es muy inteligente pensando que
el principio activo para producir las
vacunas viene precisamente de china o
transexual obsesión era el comunismo el
que llegó a llamar el coronavirus de
como una virus y en este momento ha sido
el ministro más polémico y es centrado
estaba muy cansado de que fuese para
ellos como un anti diplomático que
intoxicaba el ambiente diplomático con
sus tweets constantes además al fin de
semana se le sumó el ángulo negocio que
pidió también la cabeza de araúxo porque
estamos muy preocupados con el tema de
las exportaciones
del ministro de defensa- acevedo es
diferente ha servido representa el ala
más moderada del ejército él ha
intentado mantener un poco la distancia
del lado más extremista de bolsonaro por
ejemplo cuando el año pasado el
presidente participó de manifestaciones
que pedían que se cerrase en la corte
suprema- él ha intentado alejarse un
poquito y parece que por eso
precisamente bolsonaro ha perdido su
cabeza porque quiere un ejército más
presente lo que pasa que los grandes
generales no acarree cialis la idea de
un golpe militar muy por lo contrario y
tenemos aquí una pincelada importante
esta semana el 31 de marzo se celebra el
aniversario del golpe militar que dio
inicio a la dictadura ha servido en los
últimos dos años hizo un discurso
bastante tranquilo en el que digamos él
se mostraba un demócrata y parece que
bolsonaro quiere un discurso que exalte
muchos militares no consideran
dura y si una revolución